A significant new boost for Ukraine's
fight against Russia.
First reported here on CNN.
The United Kingdom sending Long-Range
Cruise missiles to Ukraine
just ahead of Kyiv's expected
counteroffensive against Russia.
Our Brian Todd is digging
deeper on the impact
this potentially could have out there
on the battlefield.
Brian, what are you learning?
Wolf, we've learned that these new British
missiles
can strike deep into the heart
of Russian held territory in Ukraine.
But they were only delivered
after the Ukrainians made an important
promise to the British government.
A senior U.S.
military official tells CNN it's a game
changer for Ukraine on the battlefield.
The storm shadow cruise missile.
CNN chief national security correspondent
Jim Sciutto reports.
Great Britain has now delivered
multiple storm shadow missiles to Ukraine.
A weapon
that has the capability to strike deep
into Russian held territory
in eastern Ukraine.
Jim Sciutto cites a Western official
as saying Britain has received
assurances from the Ukrainian government
that the missiles will only be used
within Ukrainian sovereign territory,
not inside Russia.
It's notable that U.K.
officials have said repeatedly
they view Crimea
as sovereign Ukrainian territory
illegally annexed by Russia.
So this leaves open the possibility,
at least, that Ukrainian forces
can use this not only to attack
Russian forces in eastern Ukraine,
but also in Crimea, which Russia views
as strategically important
as this video from the manufacture
and BDA missile systems shows,
the storm shadow is launched
from the air flies low to the ground,
and its range is what will make
the difference for the Ukrainians.
155 miles, about triple
the range of the missiles
the Ukrainians have
that were provided by the U.S..
What part
of Russia's forces can Ukraine degrade
with the new storm shadow?
It's going to allow them
to strike much deeper
and to go after especially fixed targets,
whether it be ammunition depots or runways
or any kind of big installation
that the Russians
have been able to operate with impunity.
The storm shadow doesn't complete
Ukraine's wish list.
The Ukrainians have long
been asking the U.S.
to provide the long range surface
to surface army tactical missile systems,
called by their acronym attack ships
that have a range of 185 miles.
But analysts say
the Storm Shadow has capabilities
that the attack system doesn't have.
Those capabilities include a GPS
snap of the Earth navigation capability.
And the reason for that,
it actually allows for more efficient
use of firepower
and more effective targeting
Now, this
isn't the first time that Britain has gone
further than the U.S.
in providing Ukraine with advanced
weaponry and sometimes doing it sooner.
Britain was the first ally to commit to
sending modern Western tanks to Ukraine.
The challenge to tanks before the U.S.
announced it would send the M1
Abrams tanks Wolf.
Brian Todd reporting for us.
Thank you very much.
Joining us now is Matthew Schmitt,
an associate
professor of national security
and political science at the University
of New Haven in Connecticut.
It's good to see you.
Good to see you, John.
Okay, so here is the U.K.
defense minister, Ben Wallace, announcing
in parliament that Britain will do what
the US has so far been unwilling to do,
and that's provide long range missiles
Storm
Shadow is a long range, conventional,
only precision strike capability.
It complements
the long range systems already gifted,
including high models and harpoon
missiles, as well as Ukraine's own Neptune
cruise missile and longer range
missions elsewhere gifted.
The donation of these weapon systems
gives Ukraine the best chance
to defend themselves
against Russia's continued brutality.
So these are stealth missiles
or stealthy missiles which are fired
from the air by a fighter jet.
And the manufacturer says
they have the ability to deliver precision
effects from a safe stand of distance
against high value targets
such as well-protected control bunkers
and centers, key infrastructures
and military installations.
So how would you see these missiles
being used during the counteroffensive?
The first thing that they're going to do
is attack Russian artillery.
That's the number one way that the Russian
military has been killing Ukrainians.
And they will try to denude
that capability as much as they can.
The second thing that they'll do is attack
supply routes,
particularly ammo and fuel.
And then I wouldn't be surprised
if they have enough.
That's the key here, right?
How many is Britain giving them
and how fast to restock
the Kurds bridge or something
like that of high symbolic value?
And it seems the UK is sending
what is a shorter range variant.
155 miles as opposed to 350 miles.
But even at 135 miles, these missiles,
which have been used effectively in Syria,
Iran and Libya, have a capability
to strike deep into Russia.
I mean, if you get the borderline
you go 150 miles north of there
and you're deep inside Russian territory.
Now Western official told CNN
that the UK has received assurances
from the Ukrainian government
that these missiles
will be used only within Ukrainian
sovereign territory and not inside Russia.
UK officials have made frequent
public statements identifying Crimea
as Ukrainian sovereign territory,
describing it as illegally annexed.
So what happens, though, if the Ukrainians
decide not to be held to that?
Some of it is some dramatic changing event
and they decide
they need to fire these missiles
well deep into Russian territory.
What happens then?
Well, I think if there's some
dramatic event that changes the conditions
on the battlefield and changes
the political conditions
then all bets are off.
But short of something like that,
I think Ukrainians are going to
are going to very much
stay within the parameters that the U.S.
and that the U.K. have set for them.
They know where the where
the money's coming from.
They know where the weapons are coming
from, and they're not going to risk it.
And if you look what the U.S.
has been unwilling to supply the talks,
they only go a short
distance
further than the Britain missiles do.
So they don't have a lot of differences
between these two.
So does this mean that the United States
may be more inclined
to provide these longer range missiles?
That's a
pattern that we've seen throughout the war
where the Biden administration
has said no.
And then three, four or six weeks
later, has said yes
and sort of inch deeper
and deeper into the war.
So I wouldn't be surprised
if that's what happens here.
And that, in fact,
may be part of the political calculation,
which is that if the UK sort of breaks
the barrier on this,
then it's easier for the U.S.
to come along and say, well,
it doesn't matter
now, does it, because Britain did it.
So we might as well
And Britain was the first to supply
Ukraine modern better.
Thanks.
Now, the first of the long range missiles
and from the very beginning
has been pushing the U.S.
and the other allies to a lot more.
Is that mostly driven
by this long list of covert attacks on UK
soil by the Russians
the poisoning Sergei Skripal in 2018
and Alexander
actually was poisoned back in 2006.
Now I think it's part of the signaling
to Russia that they need to back off
on these attacks in the U.K.
I think a lot of it is just old school
pride and a lot of it's just revenge.
And you know whatever is remaining
of motivation I think is that the U.K.
is trying to punch above its weight again
right is trying to get back in there
and say we are one of the leading
forces of foreign policy in the world
and this is the way that they can do it.
Yeah. And it's been effective so far,
I guess.
Matthew, thanks for being with us.
We appreciate it.
My pleasure.
We're getting word of new Russian strikes
in two regions of Ukraine.
Officials say Russian artillery
and air force unleashed a barrage
of attacks on her son region, killing
at least one person.
Four others were wounded over the past
24 hours,
while separate attacks on the city
of Slovyansk.
About 600 kilometers to the northeast left
one person dead and 12 others injured.
Meanwhile, Ukraine
is reportedly working to smooth the way
for its upcoming counter-offensive.
Two senior Western officials
say Kiev has already started what's called
shaping operations
for its expected attack, which means it's
launching selective strikes
to soften Russian defenses.
For more, Scott
McClain joins us from London.
So, Scott, what more are we learning about
this so-called shaping operation
and the counteroffensive
that will presumably follow?
Yeah, so the question is whether or not
the counteroffensive has begun at all.
And for the answer,
it really depends on who you ask.
If you ask President Zelensky,
he says that the Ukrainians need
a bit more time to get more Western
weapons, more Western equipment
into the country before they can
really begin that counteroffensive.
But if you ask the head of the volunteer
private military contractor
on the Russian side, Yevgeny Prigozhin,
he says that Zelensky is lying
and that the counteroffensive
is already in full swing.
And he points to the situation in Baku
where even he concedes that
the Ukrainians have had some success
as of late.
The actual
Ukrainian military says that, yes,
it has been able to exploit some Russian
weaknesses on the flanks of this city,
particularly the northern
and southern parts of the city
where there is dynamic fighting,
in their words, going on at the moment.
And they say that
while they are definitely on offense,
they're not calling it a counter
offensive.
The deputy defense minister has said
just today that the Ukrainians
have managed to advance two kilometers
on the Russians in just the past week.
And as a result,
the Russians actually last night
had to put out a pretty unusual late
night statement denying reports
that the Ukrainians had made a major
breakthrough in the region, saying
that the situation there is under control.
Of course, the big risk for the Russians
is that the Ukrainians may be able
to push forward on those outer flanks
there and actually surround the Russians,
either pushing them,
forcing them to retreat or perhaps
forcing them to surrender
after what has been eight
months
and months of bloody fighting there.
And as you mentioned, Kim
senior Western officials are saying that
what Ukraine is doing at the moment
is something called shaping, which means
using airstrikes to take out things
like artillery systems, take up things
like command centers and weapons
depots, things like that,
in order to sort of shape the battlefield,
to make it easier for advancing troops
to actually move on the ground.
This could go on for several days
before we see anything
sort of resembling a full scale
counteroffensive.
And this is something
that we also saw ahead of the Ukrainian
counteroffensive in Harrison last summer,
which resulted in the Ukrainians
taking back
a very wide swath of territory again.
All right.
Thanks so much for the update.
Scott McClellan appreciate it.